welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Avengers infinity war just
cursed us with all kinds of knowledge
overlook cinematic details deleted
scenes alternate ways Thanos could have
broken everyone's hearts the good folks
at comic-book comm hosted Twitter wax
parties for infinity war an endgame with
the film's screenwriters Christopher
Markus Stephen McFeely and the directors
Joe and Anthony Russo chime an end that
have given us all kinds of new insights
about these movies so let's break down
all the new things we learn about
infinity war with another tweak day and
let's start with the opening scene the
writers confirmed an alternate opening
scene from earlier scripts showing how
Thanos got the Power Stone by conquering
zantar and the Nova Corps the writers
also confirmed that I have one boy Nova
Richard Ryder what's going to be
introduced as the sole survivor of that
massacre and be the Harbinger who brings
the bad news to earth but Novus cameo
was removed sadly no matter what
infinity war was gonna open with doom
like noticed a noses opening words read
it run from it
destiny arrives all the same and now
it's here what should I say I am the
writer said they wrote the speech right
after Election Day 2016 didn't use
hashtags for that tweet that we would
notice what we did no they said thinness
removes his armor and leaves it off for
the rest of the movie because upon
achieving the second Infinity stone
Thanos evolves from a warlord to mortal
religious figure infinity war is more or
less over at this point they a knows as
obstacles ahead are more personal and
intimate the writers discussed the
challenge of Tony Stark and Stephen
strangers competing egos but they found
a workable dynamic between the two by
basing them on Frasier it niles destroy
life on a scale if they're two on dreamt
odds did you seriously just say hither
200m seriously leaning on the cauldron
of the cosmos no one ever you know what
I think about pop psychiatry yes I know
what do you think about everything
when was the last time you had an
unexpressed thought I'm having one now
the guardians meet Thor and the writers
credited Taika Waititi for one of the
best lines in the movie what we have to
go is negative there that's a made-up
word it was made up back on earth the
black orders attack on vision and Wanda
and Edinboro was originally scripted to
be set in Paris where they would have
been swarmed by a whole pack of
outriders cat makes his entrance here
but they said that in the original cut
of the movie cap didn't show up until
the final act during the Battle of
Wakanda they also confirmed that the
sokovia accords at forts cap on the run
and some were still in effect during
infinity war may even be in effect to
the present day Thanos gets to the
reality stone before the guardians now
when asked why they Ono spent decades of
not going after the stones but then was
able to get them all in 24 hours the
writers explained the power of
preparation see we forget that they own
a stone grab in this movie was they
carefully timed heist by the mad Titan
that he planned for years he needed to
scoop them all up quickly before other
MCU power players could catch up to what
he was doing and try to stop him the
writers also shared a set photo showing
dr. strange wearing the Iron Man armor
oddly that version of Tony and Peter's
rescue involved the nanotech armor
billowing down to protect stranged while
Tony would have worn the cloak of
limitation and floated down another big
reveal from this watch along they
clarified the timeline plot hole of each
Rees Infinity Gauntlet mold and medieval
ear
we saw thinness with this gauntlet way
back in the post-credits scene of age of
Ultron but infinity war implied Thanos
acquired the gauntlet just recently the
riders now say the age of Ultron
gauntlet was a decorative practice
gauntlet see basically Thanos was into
collectibles than us what are you doing
in there
I'm just practicing car leave me alone
the Infinity Ward's crew nighters also
said Gamora confessing to fairness a
location of the soul stone
was based on the moment Darth Vader in
Tarkin tried to get the rebel base
location from Leia in a new hope and the
riders mentioned the return of red skull
was one of the big things that excited
them the most to work on the script as
the writers of the first Captain America
movie they were thrilled to revisits
their great villain they a nose tells
Gamora
I ignored my destiny once
I cannot do that again even
to you the writers confirm that he was
referring to his failure to save Titan
his homeworld route uses his arm to form
the handled storm breaker and the
writers point out how cool it is that
for all of Thor's future battles Groot
would be there by his side and if you
think about it for is constantly holding
hands with groups truly and as guardian
of the galaxy vanos said dr. Strange's
wizard duel was apparently based on the
one in the 1963 Vincent Price sports
Karloff film The Raven which has a
similarly insane conjuring of random
weaponry sequence danos confronts Tony
Stark
you know me I do you're not the only one
curse to acknowledge the writers say
Thanos knows him simply because Ironman
was a guy who threw a nuke at his army
in the first Avengers and by cursed with
knowledge the writers explained that
both Thanos and Tony saw their planets
doomsday is coming for years but no one
listened prior to the Battle of Wakanda
writers confirmed a deleted scene
between Bruce and Natasha that was
removed you may remember a shot from it
in the movies trailer and the final act
was actually going to reveal banners
transformation into smart Hulk and more
of a debate between the two identities
we did make another video breaking down
all that test footage to go check it out
the filmmakers cut it because it felt
like too much of a victory during the
defeats in danger they reshot all of
Ruffalo scenes at the end of infinity
war and the first 20 minutes of in-game
and Thanos his final marched his
reaction a cab grabbing his gauntlet
according to writers was they look of
surprised and respect for this man
actually the Russos revealed that early
on in production they considered making
the soulstone not a separate gem on
Vermeer but Steve Rogers himself back in
the days when I thought the soul stone
was wakanda's mount Pechanga vibranium
meteorite I fear arises that the
vibranium enriched soil of Wakanda
produced the heart-shaped herb and that
was a mystery ingredient of the Super
Soldier Serum making the soul stone
inside cap so yeah who's laughing now
mom the writers also explained that
thanasis specific order going stone by
stone was determined by the level of
sacrifice by the heroes so the power
stone required a sacrifice by really no
unimportant sorry Nova Corps but then
Thanos defeats Hulk Thor Loki for the
space stone he defeats the guardians of
the galaxy for the reality stone he
defeats Gamora slashed himself for the
soul stone he defeats Iron Man and
Doctor Strange for the time stone and
then he defeats the rest specifically
invision for the mine stone and yes
while Thor should have gone for the head
they also confirm that yes he could have
gone for the wrist too and they said
that the intention was always to leave
the original six Avengers alive so that
the second part in endgame could all be
a finale that brought the original six
back together as a tribute
so our recap of the new reveals from
Avengers endgame is coming soon but calm
down below with your favorite new detail
from infinity war follow me on instagram
twitter ITA vasa follow me rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
marble thanks for watching bye
[Music]